today we're talking about how fortnite
has snuck its way back onto the iphone
and how summer game fest has an official
date
today fortnite becomes the first
free-to-play game to hit xbox cloud
gaming you can play fortnite via the
cloud right now through the xbox website
on ios android pcs or a tablet this is
particularly noteworthy for ios players
since epic famously removed fortnite
from ios amid its battle with apple and
now this looks like a pretty good
workaround to play fortnite on your
apple devices and get this you don't
need xbox gold or game pass to stream
this what a flex microsoft also shared
some stats about xbox cloud gaming
reiterating that 10 million people have
streamed games with xbox cloud gaming
thus far through xbox game pass ultimate
additionally the company said xbox game
pass users who make use of cloud
streaming play quote nearly twice as
many games as those who don't use the
cloud and it's not hard to see why
sometimes i see a game and i'm just like
oh will i enjoy that i don't feel like
installing it let me just stream it for
a couple minutes and see what's up so if
you were a big fortnite mobile player
congrats this news is great for you it's
great for microsoft and it's great for
epic but okay let's talk about a
different type of streaming event
streaming even though e3 2022 is
cancelled the annual summer game fest
event from industry veteran jeff keely
is still going ahead summer game fest
live 2022 will take place thursday june
9th starting at 11 a.m pacific 2 p.m
eastern last year's event was a big show
that featured the first gameplay footage
of what might be the game of the year
eldon ring and the announcement of tiny
tina's wonderlands the event also had
appearances from everyone's crush ryan
reynolds jeff goldblum giancarlo
esposito as well as a musical
performance by weezer as of yet however
there is no word on what to expect from
summer gamefest 2022 but the organizers
say that viewers can look forward to
world premieres trailers news and
updates from the world's top gaming
developers and platforms in addition to
being streamed on places like youtube
and twitch summer gamefest live 2022
will be screened in some imax theaters
as well it's also worth noting that the
xbox and bethesda presentation is just a
couple days later on june 12th the xbox
division has a number of major games in
development right now such as avowd
everwild fable and senua saga hellblade
2. on the bethesda side there's red fall
elder scrolls 6 and this november star
field but alright so far we've talked
about two free things let's keep this no
money train rolling activision has
announced the latest playstation
exclusive combat pack for call of duty
warzone all playstation plus members can
jump into the battle royale now to grab
a number of freebies these include the
gold hawk and heavy foliage blueprints
as well as the all-terrain calling card
a new watch a new emblem and a new
weapon charm the bundle also includes a
double xp token and although dying light
2 stay human launched earlier this year
the first game is still being supported
with dying light's new
1.49 patch all players who own the
standard edition of the first game will
now have their copies automatically
upgraded to the enhanced edition this
version of the game includes the story
expansion pack the following as well as
4 dlc packs now hit the comments and let
me know your thoughts on streaming and
whether we're going to move towards at
all streaming future
i know my thoughts on it but i'm not
going to give them just let me know
yours i'll see you tomorrow
[Music]